what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday july the 7th
the joint is brought to you by manscaped
listen summer's here and you're ready to
show off your beachbod you're going to
show up with [__] hair on your
shoulders
[__] poof between your legs you pick
up a check you bring it back to the
hotel room you're gonna stink like a
[__]
tzatziki sauce those days are overweight
get rid of those stinky hairs
with manscape we've just revealed the
fourth performance [__] package
first up the new and improved lawnmower
4.0
trimmer i could give you a bunch of
marketing mumbo jumbo
but this is skin safe technology no
anxiety
you shave your balls right over the
[__] toilet right there you pick up
your dick you hold on to your dick tight
and you shave right around that
[__] but the bottom line is this
is designed to protect your [__]
privates
even my long balls don't get caught in
these [__] things
and the blades are sharp enough to cut
through the white hairs
which you [__] can't cut through like
butter set the length of your trim from
one to four if you're old school
they even made a [__] light for you
you could [__] shave your balls in
the dark like a savage
and they added a travel lock and made it
waterproof
so there you go you could shave in the
shower blame the pubic hairs on your
kids i didn't do it it's my [__] kids
throw this in your [__] weekend bag
and you're set for any situation and it
don't stop with your nuts
they also got the [__] weed whack as
seen right there
it'll trim up your nose and your ears
and your hairs
at a 9000 rpm motor you know this thing
got [__]
boogers out of my nose that have been in
there since the [__] 80s remember
that booger a couple months ago
that's cause of [__] uh manscape then
you got my favorites
the cop the crop preserver tremendous
for anti-shaving ball deodorant
and you also have the crop reviver which
is my all-time favorite
because it tones your balls and tightens
your nut sack
and you could also put it under your
eyes i got [__] crop revive
under my eyes right now smoking people
like you look like carrie grant
no no no no it's the ball toner and when
you get the performance package they
throw in a travel bag and
a pair of boxes who's better than you
but better yet who's better than
manscape you're gonna watch them this
week
when you watch the ufc they're right
there with the ring because they want
every man in that [__] [__] place
to have nice
smell well balls you understand me you
want your balls to be in tip-top
condition
and that's where manscape comes in so do
me a favor get 20
off and free worldwide shipping that's
right even you and india
just because you got covet don't mean
you gotta shave your nut sacks
go to manscape.com joey that's
20 off and free worldwide shipping by
going to manscape.com
joey no more stinky hairs on your nut
sack
with manscape let's get this party
started we got the lee interview part
two
welcome to uncle joy's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday
the 7th of july a beautiful day to be
alive
we're back uh what the [__] has happened
in two days
nothing i had my guitar lessons listen i
am digging my [__] guitar lessons
it's the only thing that's uh it's a
hobby
um like i said sometimes hobbies are
better than [__] uh
going for something i'm 58 it's not like
uh
you know i told mike the dad got up with
the guitar for the first time
like i always play it sitting down you
know what i'm saying but i stood up with
the guitar and tried to play it
not too good you know how sometimes you
get up too fast and you get dizzy yeah
it was the same thing
only the guitar was dizzy like todd was
like begging me sit back down
this is not [__] working but i'm i'm
digging it
i know the beginning to ac dc i'm
working on cocaine by eric clapton
i wanted him to teach me the a couple
lines from heartbreaker
and it's just fun that's it on there's
no expectations
i'm not learning how to read music i
don't want to join a band i don't want
to do none of that
it's you know throughout this whole
thing
it's just been a hobby like some people
collect stamps
some people watch porn for me you know
this [__] house shuts down at [__]
nine o'clock at night like my wife and
the baby i'm like oh
we're tired okay go to bed so what am i
gonna do come down here and watch tv the
same [__] every [__] night
so i try to do different things i make
notes for erica
to write the book uh this week we should
be signing the [__] deal
for the audiobook and the regular book
we got nine chapters under our
[__] belts
um [__] laughing gas will be out july
16th
at the ice cream shop in studio city and
then we'll get it out to other stores
i will keep you posted on what stores
but you need to do me a favor
you need to go to at laughing gas 2gs at
the end
on instagram right now just do me that
[__] favor at laughing gas
if you're a [__] professional [__]
head like me
and you want this reef it's going to be
it's not too strong it's not too it's
not no susquehanna
there's no susquehanna uncle joey's life
you know i don't like that [__]
even though i gave mike some new jersey
susquehanna the other day
and it was not susquehanna it was
tremendous weed
i smoked a little butt of it and i was
impressed it didn't take me to [__] in
marsville
but excuse me it took me to where i
needed to be you understand so it wasn't
bad my uh
my nephew gave me some jersey weed it
was [__] pretty good i want to run it
by mike
so at least jersey's making a [__]
climb for it but you know
us we're always running with the [__]
ziki
we don't give a [__] they're the ones
that helped me put together
the laughing gas and you know i've been
smoking with them for three
four [__] years it's tremendous reef
i hope you enjoy it
listen i hope you enjoyed monday's
podcast with lee syat
we didn't lie to you we taped two parts
and uh today
we go a little deeper into what happened
with the therapist and all this [__]
so uh i hope you enjoyed it it was great
seeing him
let's go to the video replay enjoy lisa
yo what's up well it's been a long time
it's [__] wednesday [__]
i wanted to do this in two parts so
we were talking about when we took off
on monday we were talking about
you getting into therapy right and
i started seeing your mood getting a
little darker
you were getting darker you were having
trouble sleeping
and that's when i was
taking a look at that podcast and
feeling the weight of it
i'm sorry i i'm i'm i feel bad then
no okay i don't want you to apologize
because by you going to therapy it
opened up my mind
okay open up my mind to
to think about what the [__]
this poor kid's in therapy what am i
doing to him
where is his mind going at night with
these edibles
all of a sudden there was an air of
guilt to me
i had this guilt to me and the other
guilt was
this kid's been doing this for six years
i think you were about to turn 30.
probably yeah at the time yep
and i was like you know what man i'm 50
something
i've done time i've done this
you know i got my dick sucked behind the
church you know
you do all these things and you you're
proud of some of the stuff
but you're not proud of some of the
other stuff
you weren't doing any of those things i
was encouraging you to going out
you know you were getting paid you had
access to weed you had access to [__]
edibles you had access to
i mean you could have been your whole
new cosby you can
dump [__] abx and every chick's drink
at a [__] bar and
see who passes out first but uh
you know you didn't you weren't doing
those things in fact you got
even more isolated and on the flip side
of that
i was doing the same thing in my house
all those edibles and all that [__]
and all the the stupidity from the
podcast from the people
canceling to people not showing
to i was thinking of this one [__]
girl
don't mention her name okay that got to
the podcast
late and then she had the balls to look
me in the face and go oh by the way
i don't do any longer than 30 minutes on
a podcast
yeah and two weeks later
i see you doing three hours on rogan
and you're like you know you you can't
win you
try everything you can i knew the girl
for years i was always very sweet though
we had a great relationship you know
doing comedy and all of a sudden you
come in here with that attitude you know
it was it was all those things
that made me think i mean you were and
then you got into comedy
and i didn't know where that had come
from you know you wanted to do comedy
and you were really working it you were
heading out to the fourth wall you were
really doing it
on the other hand i was feeling guilty
because i couldn't take you with you
me with you because i had you with me
all week
now i'm going to take you with me on the
road and we're going to really [__]
hate each other you know what i'm saying
right and i got dean delray i got all
these other people who at a different
level who also needed money
so i wanted to spread the wealth you
know i wanted to spread it around
all my friends you know when you
started doing comedy i got really
nervous
really now yeah you were going to
different spots at night
and i always felt i was a little
responsible for you like things you
didn't know when i was coming back from
the store
i would drive by your house just to make
sure the [__]
your house wasn't on fire and i remember
one of the angriest you ever got at me
was one of our first sponsors it was
hulu
i was having a party at comic-con in san
diego
so i took my ex down there and redband
was having a show
and it got back because i had a couple
drinks
before the show and it got back to you
that i had driven home drunk from san
diego which i didn't
um i had like a couple drinks before but
then in the two hours of the show i had
sobered up
um and you called me
like angry but like be out of out of
love like you
you would always do that you there was a
lot of times
towards the end especially during i
guess not right before covet and a
little bit after
is you would just show up at my
apartment and we would
take an edible do it uh like sit in the
car for 10 minutes
like you brought me cuban fried rice a
couple times
like you you did care about and then
like i i
um you would always get like nervous
if i was going on the road like driving
a long ways like you
i think if people thought about you they
might think like you don't really get
nervous or like
not that you don't care about people but
like you get like you could actually
like really
like i always i would call you like when
i got home from places like i'm home
don't worry about it
like you would and you might say in a
funny way like don't go down there what
are you going down there for
but like it's it's coming from a place
of like i
i don't want you to get hurt like i
remember i drove uber
for like a month and you really didn't
like that
you're like what am i going to tell your
mom if someone stabs you in the heart
yeah he's driving why is he driving uber
you're paying them you know
mike leaves here and i tell mike the
first thing when you get home hit me
back
right whenever i go out at night i drive
by jimmy's house i drive by christina's
house
all my friends just to make sure there's
no creepy people in front of there you
know you were on my watch
i was on your watch yeah and
i wanted that love to come through the
screen
i think that's what people appreciate
the most about the podcast that's what
people hated when i
first came back with zoom they didn't
see the love across the stream that's
why i gotta
tell people i can't put people on zoom
if i don't know you
right i'd love to get you on you're very
interesting but
they got to feel that connection you
know i cared about you
i wanted the best for you and at the end
like when the pandemic hit do you
remember us having a [__]
specific i want you to tell me the truth
a specific
talk may be the beginning of april where
we both looked at each other and we said
a lot of things are going to change from
this pandemic
people are gonna change their minds oh
there was a
like two or three at least if not four
podcasts about that ex
like very topic yeah did you ever
thought that it was gonna be
us when we were having those
conversations
i didn't pre-think it at all but like i
said last week
you you made it very clear
from like almost the beginning as soon
as you had mercy
that you didn't want to raise her in la
so
when you called and told me that you
were leaving
i wasn't i wasn't shocked by it when
i remember around march
when like you started to hear about it
in europe and asia and it wasn't really
here yet
and
i i would take walks with steve simone
and jimmy jimmy schubert
and we would talk and and even like even
the president said it'll be gone by
easter and then we thought maybe by july
it'd be over and then it just
it got to the point where like already
before then
i wasn't doing much and then there was
literally
like we probably weren't even supposed
to be doing the podcast
i think i even asked you that once and
he laughed at me like listen were you
still gonna do the podcast
but like that was the only time we were
leaving the house
from like the middle of march or april
through august when we were there it was
all we were doing
and to be honest it made
like i i wouldn't i i'm i wouldn't have
said i'm leaving
[__] the podcast but it makes sense like
it just it
it it didn't make sense to keep living
like that and it just
ended imagine if we'd been there until
april of this year
living wearing masks on the podcast
guests didn't want to come i mean it
would have been awful it would have been
terrible
the way i looked at it was
i looked at what we had done
i looked at the situation in my house
you know my daughter wasn't in school
right you hated that it was weighing on
it it was weighing on my wife
it was weighing on me um
comedy was weighing on me you know when
you go to pee in the morning
and you have a knot in your stomach
because you got to go to the store
or the only thing i really enjoyed was
that office
and that podcast you know yeah it was
great to
go there at night and find the [__]
pill
you know what kind of pill you got no
computer to see what mmd is so
you wouldn't have looked it up anyways
yeah i wouldn't have looked it up anyway
you know they were all great things
but all good things must come
to an end right and the name of these
two episodes is
living in hell and not knowing it
we were living in a hell and we didn't
know it you know i lived in hell and i
didn't know it
before i went to prison i lived in hell
and i didn't know it while i was married
the first time
and i think the last four years of the
podcast
we lived in hell and had no idea we were
living there
i mean it's so weird to say this until
the day
that i threw the the table off the
[__] thing to salami and brett and
we were done with the boxes and damon
was helping us pull down the things
when i ripped those walls off i was like
we were in hell in here
this was just a different form of a
prison you know when chris cornell sings
fell on black days he he talks about
doing time
he was he wasn't talking about doing
time he was talking about doing that
mental time
something's weighing on you something
was weighing on you
the thing that was weighing on me the
most was one
we had done 800 episodes we had nothing
else to prove
two i could see
that
if you stayed a little longer i thought
something bad was gonna happen either
you would snap
call me one day and say you can't do it
no more i could see you
slowly going into a depression it was a
slow
depression i was calling you at 10 and
you were just waking up you couldn't
sleep at night
so all these things were weighing on me
then i thought about myself when i was
and i was making good money and i
thought i was having a good time being a
bookie i thought i was cool and [__]
and i go i can't keep doing this the
rest of my life
this is not gonna work out i'm not gonna
get a resume after this
you know what happens if i do this tom
31 this was funny because i kept
here i was 21 and i'm like what if i do
this till i'm 21
or 31 what happens if they get busted
how am i gonna get
another [__] job you know how the
[__] am i gonna get another job
who's gonna hire me nobody i got no
[__] work history
so i started looking at you and then
july 12th was when
[__] [__] nut newsome
said there's not gonna be any [__]
school for the rest of the year
and that devastated me and my wife
and i took my wife in the other room and
i remember saying
i spoke to jimmy florentine his
sister-in-law is going to call you
we're going to buy a house and my wife
going so
what are we going to do we're just going
to pick up and leave and move
and we'll get lee an apartment you know
and i remember calling jim and going jim
do you think she could find lee an
apartment and legos
and she goes she's gonna finally an
apartment but it's gonna be
four times over this isn't an apartment
town you know and i'm like [__] he's
gonna have to be like an old bridge a
[__] uh you know genghis khan
or whatever the [__] town this is you
know so i started thinking about and i
go wait a second
this [__] kid is living in hell it
doesn't take a genius
you didn't want to date anymore uh
you were eating to kill the pain the
same pain i was
killing with the [__] edibles and the
[__] xanax you know had had that
xanax for [__]
20 years in my house never ate as xanax
before started watching world news
tonight
and my panic went into i remember nights
that i would get in the car get out of
the car get in the car get out of the
car that's not normal
that's not normal this is the first time
i'm exposing this on on
on a podcast there was nights that i
would get in the car
out of the car 10 times and then i would
just sit on the couch
and try to get my composure to me and
tell my wife to bring me ice so i could
put it on my forehead
yeah you never told me that and she'd go
you got to go do the podcast
go you know like i had all those
episodes another night i had that when i
was going to a ufc fight at my friend
todd's house
you know i was just the the fear of the
of the [__] uh you know i didn't want
to die
and i didn't want to give it to you and
i didn't want to give it to a guest
i didn't know if it was real i didn't
know what the [__] was going on so
but back to the situation with my wife i
told my wife
i don't think i'm taking league i'm not
doing him any favors
i'm not doing any favors in this life
he's uh
in a rut i'm in a rut
but i'm in a different rut i was in a
way different rut than you were i i
was enjoying doing the podcast
i thought we were going a little
overboard with the drugs
i couldn't believe what i was smoking
right you know i started looking at what
i was smoking and
knew that this wasn't gonna end well
you know i have stomach problems today
little noises and [__] i hear from time
to time
really you know what do you think you're
gonna hear after you eat ten thousand
[__] eligible stars that have that
certo in it or whatever it is to hold
that gel together you know that's gotta
not be good to you
you know i mean we were eating
everything there wasn't anything that we
didn't put
we were trying i reminded you of the
tubes the other day oh yeah
oh my god like little five hour energies
of those yeah they were like five hour
energy
pure thc 100 tube
you know we were talking about that the
other night i mean there was just so
many [__]
things we were doing wrong but the thing
i felt i was doing the worst was
it's like what you said you know i was
bringing you
cuban fred rice which is
20 000 calories on its own well you did
that like twice it wasn't like every day
you were bringing that
and i mean the edibles you always
thought i always
i feel like i hurt your feelings a
couple of times you always thought when
i would say oh
i'm gaining weight because of the
edibles or partly because of the edibles
i'm i'm an adult you didn't force me i
mean and you eat edibles and you didn't
gain weight
first of all i didn't give a [__] about
your weight gain i had my own problems i
was going home and eating
six salami sandwiches three apples a bag
of pirates booty
right swiss cheese i haven't touched
salami
since october damn i was going through
a pound of salami every three days
like just go home at night and start
with a salami a piece of salami two
salamis three salad i got no bread
and then i would eat [__] two salami
sandwiches you know
i would stay up till three in the
morning get up at seven
you know yeah and walk around with mercy
and think that was okay no naps all day
yeah and then going into the toxicity
which is comedy yep you know i was i was
i was poisoning my body i was poisoning
the temple of doom
and on top of that i'm [__] toxic
from these [__] desperate
people that are walking around you you
know
always trying to get something from you
always trying to come into you on a
light and and
it got to the point where i didn't know
who was who anymore
i loved you i love steve i love jerry
rocha i love di agustino i mean you
young guys were the guys that were the
glue in my life
you know eric rocha you guys were the
glue mike
the [__] stars of comedy and those
guys they were just
you know hi it's great to see you oh my
god how is toledo
uh get the [__] out of here right you
know
it all sucks we were all lying to
ourselves i was lying to myself
i was saying to myself oh i'm having a
good time this is what i should be doing
until i found myself on a plane thursday
saturday and sunday i would get off the
[__] plane on a sunday and my back
hurt for [__] two days
you know and then i'd have to go work
out and all this [__] but the
the final thing was lee i just wanted
you to have a normal [__] life and i
wanted you
you your confidence was low yeah
um my confidence was low
i needed your confidence to come back
you were a happy [__] kid when we
started i remember we went to see grudge
match
at the movie theater with [__] salami
all of us we were happy [__] people
yeah that had disappeared that had
disappeared that that
podcast had we took the podcast and
turned it into a job
you know that's why i couldn't take a
[__] week off
i felt that people [__] depended on
us
you know but then you put the podcast
out and
tell lee to fix the [__] hearing yeah
i can't hear the [__] thing
you got too high you shouldn't have worn
an atlanta braves shirt on yeah
it was like we're giving you content for
free
right and you're still [__] bitching
you know
that's why now i do what i do i don't
give a [__] if you like it you like it
if you don't
but watch the other [__] podcast go
watch disney plus i don't give a [__]
what's your [__] watch
i really don't you're taking it or
you're not taking it
i can't hear it it's not perfect well
nothing is
it's pirate [__] radio you [__]
morons right
sir i know three guys that work at
sirius they're doing their [__]
shows on their phones nobody's going
into [__] serious building it's a
ghost town
go to sirius in new york bang on the
windows
ain't nobody gonna answer the [__]
door for you right
this is this was pirate radio since day
one
that this was not wplj or wnew
or sirius we weren't supposed to be
[__]
uh uh uh a [__] 20
000 operation but that also happened to
specials
people started oh well you have to have
three hundred thousand dollars to shoot
a special my friend shot one for eight
thousand dollars and it's got a million
downloads on [__] youtube what are
you talking about
i remember you hated whenever you saw
the crane shot every time you saw the
crane
at any of your tapings or anywhere
you're like i hate that why do we need a
crane what do we need
for it's a camera straight up why are we
[__] you know
and then i read keith richards book he
does a whole chapter on live music
that we've gotten so [__] smart we've
forgotten about [__] live music you
know how to do it
how they forgot how to wire the [__]
drums to do live music
because everything was so technical
everything was so [__] technical we
forgot
you know people wanted perfection at all
levels and this isn't it's pirate radio
guy
right it's pirate radio i saw when joe
opened up his
thing in austin i read the remarks oh
yeah
i don't like it it's a bamboo
shut the [__] up when you do a podcast
then come talk to me
when you do 800 episodes then you come
and tell me whatever the [__] you want
until then you got to suck my dick right
that's it
it's that simple the 800 [__]
episodes
they all got over [__] you know a
hundred thousand views on them and
you're still [__] complaining that's
the the non-gratitude and during covert
it got worse
yeah oh yeah it got worse it got really
worse
i didn't see i didn't see uh
it it just wasn't pleasant anymore
people were unhappy and that's why i
wanted to keep doing the podcast
because i wanted just to just give them
one hour that we would goof around
you know and just talk [__] and grab a
joint and don't
get away from the [__] news and i was
watching the news also
getting scared to death yeah but i never
wanted you to think that i didn't love
you
i never wanted you to think that i got
rid of you
what i did was i wanted to give you a
fair
chance at life in eight years from now
and you call me and you go hey dog
we got to start a podcast up i gave life
a chance
my wife dumped me for a lesbian you know
uh i can't get my dick sucked it's time
to do a podcast i'd love to do a podcast
with you
i loved it this would be great but
at that time we needed to end it to move
on with our lives
oh absolutely and what has happened
let's let's let's go over
what has happened
we both have podcasts yep guess what
we're under the radar
nobody gives a [__] about what we say no
more
they're all focused on the big guns
right
you got healthier all right you got
healthier on your own
no drama no nothing you do it by
yourself
with a bunch of patreon you started a
patreon you started a podcast
you banged some jubroad you got a couple
of jew broads up in milwaukee you got
those [__] viking jews that you know
yeah they don't like these ghosts they
like the cold weather you got those
viking jews you know i'm saying they
don't wear a yarmulke they wear a
yarmulke with like a stocking
it's the whole [__] thing everybody
wants to be [__] barbra streisand and
that movie yentl
oh jesus and uh
i'm really [__] proud of you like i'm
really
[__] proud of you that you kept it
going for 10 months you didn't give a
[__] you got yourself a little [__]
office
and i knew this was going
to happen i did not know
i was gonna cut down on the marijuana
i would never have guessed that the dog
please i did not know i was going to cut
down the marijuana
i did not know i was going to cut down
on the edibles
i did not know that
i wasn't gonna go back to stand up right
away
i definitely needed a [__] break from
that
and the [__] i was going through
with that
and i definitely didn't know that i
would end up
a little sad at times a little bored
a little lonely at times but you know
what
it all worked out you know yeah friday
night i went to eat
with some families you know this is
wednesday today so
friday night i went to eat with some
families and
one of the families their husband works
a lot good great guy i love him to that
great guy
but he didn't make it to dinner and she
was there with the two kids and
it was great we had a great time the
kids were running around we took
pictures
the [__] and they had real japanese
people at the steakhouse by the way
which i was
no [__] mexicans with scotch tape on
their eyes not like benihana in l.a
they were making choo-choos the guy was
shooting saki in my [__] mouth i
almost puked and [__]
with like a butter thing i was like this
my daughter was proud because
they threw up cucumbers and me and my
wife caught him in the first try
like seals and [__] and i told my wife
we were both in the circus in cuba
and she's like that's a lie that's a lie
you mommy never worked in a circus i'm
telling you we worked in the circus in
cuba
but i noticed that dude missing from the
table
yeah and that used to be my wife
and the first thing she says is excuse
uh my husband
he's got to work at 11 o'clock tonight
and he figured he'd get a couple hours
of sleep before work he works uh
11 to 8. and right away i thought about
my wife
and this is my what my wife was doing
for the last [__]
10 years you know going to things by
herself she was like [__]
the guy from the godfather that
represents
vito you know she was like whatever his
name is
yeah she always had to show up to things
you know and by herself with my daughter
you know for three weeks i went to new
york she had to do it all those things
started to bother me when i got here and
it's okay
like it's okay so now i'm
i'm with her you know i got to all the
softball games
i i want to be a part of life especially
these crucial years
stand up will always be there uncle
vinnie's my favorite comedy club in the
country will always be there
the boy gotta always be there your boy
up and laugh boston will always be there
your boy at the world will always be
there
if i want to do it i'll do it if not
i'm not but my biggest [__]
happiness is that you and i
had a great talk three weeks ago and
we both saw where we were at the love
was still there
that there was tons of love still there
it had just gotten interrupted by the
drugs and uh
and there was a lot of drugs you know
none of them illegal just weed and
edibles but it was to a different
[__] level
uh we got to see the devil which is very
important you got to see the devil
before you could see god
and liv we saw god yeah it's
um i always said la was like a business
trip i don't think anyone ever like like
there's a few people who like it
whatever
it felt like a business trip like you
and i like i spent things
more thanksgivings with you out there
than anybody
i never the fact that i got to spend
thanksgiving with my mom
it was the first thanksgiving i'd seen
her in ten years
and then i spent two months i spent my
dad's birthday with him
if i spent two months in florida i get
to see my aunt and uncle a lot now you
you would always tell me it's good to go
back
to your mom's or just to your your
hometown to like restart
and it
it's not where i would have like
seen my life going at 32
but over the past year
i feel like i've like i've
really i'm building a really good
foundation
for the rest of my life i feel like i
like i've gotten
a lot a lot i didn't realize how big i'd
gotten
i i got really big
i i wasn't
i wasn't doing enough stuff outside of
the church
because i just i would make excuses
about
about oh i have to be ready for when
joey wants and
and yeah i mean we didn't have a
schedule but there was plenty of time
for me to do other stuff
and i
even though i'm not uh like i'm still
building some which
you always say by the way like you
always say like one month you'll make
four
the next month you'll make six the next
month you'll make eight
i'm actually building something for
myself
and i've i get to have dinner with my
mom every night
i get um i get to like
get healthy and and mental health
going back to earlier this episode and
last week and last on monday too
it's always been something i've
struggled with but
towards the end of l.a
i just it was a bad i i wasn't suicidal
or anything but it just
things start to pile up and when you're
only
focused on business or when i was only
focused on the podcast and
i didn't care about my health and you're
right i didn't have any interest in
dating and
i had friends but they were all comedian
friends
i just wasn't like a real person
like i just i did a couple things
and i had a blast on the podcast for the
most part and
yeah there were times where i i i wasn't
super happy but it wasn't
like anything that you did or it just
you go through down periods but
coming back and and doing this
it's not what i want my whole life to be
i i'm
i'm by the end of this year i'm planning
on being out of my mom's house
um but it's
it's just been great to see that i can
actually do it even
the losing the weight thing and i think
you can relate
i've always given up like you had bobby
bobby kelly on your podcast a few weeks
ago and he has a joke that i love
that he says he's on a sixth fat
and i've i've always given up at like 70
pounds
or like that that would be like the top
most times i would lose 10 pounds and
i'd have a bad day and
i would just say [__] it who's gonna
care but just
it's it's proving to me that i can do it
and if i can if i can lose a hundred
pounds
then i can definitely build a business
then i can definitely find a wife then
it's it's just i got i
i was always very focused on money and i
still
am but it it's good to have goals that
aren't related to that
and to prove to myself that i can do
things and build like you said build up
my confidence
and it's uh as [__] up as this last
year was
i'm hoping that in five ten years we'll
look back at it as probably one of the
best years of our lives
my wife said it the other day best she
goes you know
i hated what kovit did to society i'm
sorry for all the grandmas and uncles
and people who lost
family members i got a call from my
sister the other night
she cannot get uh
you know the lady who brought me in she
passed
march 20th it's gonna take
12 weeks to get the rock engraved
the headstone because they're backed up
from covert
all the covert debts you know how
chilling that is to even say on the air
that backed up from all the culvert
that's the
grinding out of the tombstones you know
i i really feel bad for that but if you
listen to that podcast from
april i also said there was going to be
a silver lining to all this
we're going to have a tremendous silver
lining
and the silver lining for you was
getting both of your feet under you
starting your own business i know you're
doing well with consultations you're
building a studio for people
you're really going after it and
for me it was seeing my family looking
at
uh knowing that let me tell you
something
kami as a hobby was a lot
better than comedy as a profession right
and when i do go back
when i'm ready it's gonna be more of a
hobby
it's not going to be a profession it's
not going to define me
it was too much it was too much
you know i look at instagram now and i
see these
comics you know taking pictures and
and it's like it's too much that's not
what we were programmed to do
they're programming this desperation in
you and there's neediness in you
and i didn't like it that that was the
weight i lost
that was the real weight i lost it's not
the physical weight
i lost that weight on my shoulders that
i couldn't do nothing
without picking up an envelope that's a
great statement but it's really not
you should be able to want to go to
uncle vinnie's on a tuesday night and do
a guest set just for the sake of it
right yeah i was going to the store and
picking up 15
but i saw i was also picking up a nice
envelope in the main room
that's why i was going there right it
was just for the 15
i don't think i would have gotten maybe
i would have
because it's the comedy store i want to
reteach myself
i'm looking for a pizza place that has
an open mic
right oh that has eight people in it i'm
gonna start one
just a pizza place listen let me come in
here on tuesday put eight people in here
you know because that's all i want a
pizza place like rick dukeman used to
have
rick dukeman's mother lived in ohio his
mother-in-law and
he would do letterman and then drive to
ohio
and [__] and his wife would go where you
going he goes i got to start my new set
there's a pizza parlor down
the corner that does comedy i really i
really don't want nobody to see me
right i just want to get back into this
[__] you know thing
not ready i'm not ready right now but i
am so proud that because of you
i speak to a therapist now that's wild
that's great
i speak to a therapist
i've made some great progress with her
as you could tell by looking at me
i still got my [__] problems you know
i still got
my problems but we're not where we were
early
and that was just 10 months ago
next it is crazy how quickly that works
it's
10 months ago i mean uh
we did uh the whole month of july
and then we did eight episodes and what
[__] two weeks
yeah we we moved to both of our houses
we moved the studio and then we had we
had episodes right up until the last
week
august yeah yeah because i think we even
did two of them without like a wall we
only had like a wall
we did like four of them like i was like
i had like the
we had like uh beach chairs that we were
sitting in
that's right we had beach chairs we were
like i was
uh resting the cameras on like a box or
something
like it went it was kind of a cool way
to end as weird as it was because it
kind of brought us back to like
when we first started it we were using
lysol white bottles as
uh tripods for the webcams and it sort
of
it sort of ended that way like it just
uh
we had some great and then even i i
think about this a lot sam tripoli came
on towards the end and we had a
very emotional episode but he even was
saying like to me and i don't even know
if you remember what he was like
like you'll go back you'll lose weight
you'll get healthy
and it uh yeah i just
like my mom even told me when i first
started losing weight like when you got
home i
i was worried you were gonna have a
heart attack i mean
it yeah i was we were very worried about
you
yeah it wasn't good you knew we were
very very worried about
you yeah i kept pushing you to go to the
doctor
i kept pushing you and i came back did
all that stuff
in fact i got to go back next week and
do more blood work and oh jesus
yeah but i'm okay with it now now okay
you're not scared of it anymore let me
tell you something
the the last six months
for me were not goodly i had heart
palpitations
and insomnia and whatever
uh i finally from advice from people
you know advice from my brother jerry
rocha
nobody's got better advice to give you
when they're staring at debt
you know and uh my heart goes out to
jerry
i'm gonna take some of the patreon money
and send it to him
at the end of this month and we get paid
on the fifth
uh for his uh recovery he's a great guy
and he
he did more for me than any therapist
did with one conversation you know wow
that's great
but uh
yeah i i'm happy i did the therapy i'm
happy i'm on the medication
you know i'm doing great on the
medication i think i needed it
30 years of doing coke is not healthy
for you
and then eight years on looking for the
devil in search of the devil on the
patriot on
uh the church what's happening now
doesn't do you any favors
right i mean you're a real family man
now like every time i call you like i
went to a softball game
we did this like you're like you're
basically a stay-at-home dad now i mean
you're trying you're still working doing
the podcast doing a lot of stuff
but it's it's very it's almost like like
the nerdy guy
from back to the future who's just like
home and like
like you you i remember towards the end
of la
you got very upset even before covet
about being home at night and you were
like bored to
like you had nothing to do in your mind
and you were very bored
and you're doing
less than that like less uh like comedy
wise and
and you're home more now and you've
you've never even said once like oh i'm
losing my mind here it's too quiet here
there's nothing to do here it really
seems like you're really enjoying it
wait i never had a normal childhood i
never had
normal teenage years and i didn't have a
normal
adult life i've always been
i've been out since 1979 every night
jesus that's close to what 42 years
yeah i've been out at night i'm 58 years
old
you know what rich vaz had a birthday
party last wednesday
at tiff's you know the comedy dojo right
i wanted to go in the worst [__] way
but i gotta tell you something
couldn't do it couldn't leave my family
not yet not yet i'm not ready for
big social stuff i'm hoping i'm ready
for guns and roses
[__] september 11th in atlantic
city
oh yeah that's what i'm hoping i'm ready
for mentally that i could go in
there i mean i remember when you told me
you went to florida and you went to a
greek place and the place had 300
people with no mask oh it's just [__]
ran out of there and i'm like yeah
it's going to take time it's going to
take time for me it's been
it's been great i don't wear a mask the
other day some guy was sitting next to
me
double mask and i got anxiety just
sitting next to him
but what i wanted to say with these two
podcasts is that you're my brother
you always have a space on my table
i don't want you at but
because
you were there from the beginning um
i wanted you to have this life this was
the life you deserved
not hanging out with a 58 year old
doing a podcast hanging out with other
old people
i wanted you with 30 year olds getting
your dick sucked
getting chlamydia you needed to get
syphilis you needed to get crabs
you needed to get a tongue in your ass
there were so many things you needed
that i couldn't provide for you thank
goodness i'm saying
i just couldn't provide for you that you
had to reach
on your own and i couldn't tell you
these things
last august and it broke my heart
because
deep down inside i knew you were smart
enough
and you would put this together that you
couldn't keep living the way you were
living
and i couldn't keep living the way i was
living and at the end of the day
it wasn't that we were enemies or bad
for each other
we enabled each other you know that
[__] guy called me last week with the
sandwiches great guy
oh yeah oh god great the spicy italian
oh it looks good
i don't know if you know this but we're
shipping sandwiches across the country
now
i'm like listen i'm three minutes away
from the best sandwich in new jersey you
want to ship me a sandwich in a [__]
box with dry pepperoni
what are you crazy ship those to people
in cleveland who don't know better
and what would you think about the
[__] subway tune i told you there was
no tuna in that [__] subway
i just knew once i tasted it the way it
went down that's not tuna that's like a
goldfish
there's a bunch of kids crying outside a
[__] subway where's my goldfish
where's my goldfish
they've been serving goldfish for years
those [__] that was one of the
most upsetting things
you would have these theories that
seemed way out
there but then like it would turn out to
be right i forget there there was a
bunch of them
about like just yeah like the subway one
about like the the the stray cats in
korea town you you would say some wild
[__] to me
you never saw cat cats were all over la
you go to korea town
there's no cats but there's a special on
mushu pork
what the [__] is going on here what are
you [__] kidding me or what
you know yeah it's crazy but not but i
think i uh i love you too i think you
know that
um i love your family you really took me
in
at a time where i really didn't have
anybody in l.a i had some friends from
some of the tv shows i worked on but in
la
if you live 20 minutes from somebody
you're not going to see
you're not going to see it and and you
you always included me in holidays you
included me and bro you took me out
one of the last things we did together
is on my birthday you took me to uh the
honeydew
and you just like i can't have you at
home on your birthday
you um you treated my parents great you
let my mom come to the wilbur that one
time my dad
turned him into a zombie at in oxnard
with the stars
when we had to carry him out in front of
kishi and [__]
he went knocked out he went dog he had
one arm around lee and one around
somebody else felicia
felicia and his little legs were
dragging for the [__] car
because he took he took three he took
three of the reds uh 375 and he
loved it we had a great time your
daughter
i don't know if you remember this your
daughter was maybe like one two
maybe three and i came over your place
and we had spent some time together and
we were saying goodbye on the porch
and she went in and slammed the door on
me she's like it's enough it's enough of
him
i got to see her uh you it's weird
to me i we spent a lot more time
together before mercy but we really
didn't
it was only a couple years and to see
how happy you are
as a dad is great to see like i see the
pictures of her
winning winning softball is great
and just the fact that i i said this to
you because like right at the beginning
we weren't sure if i was going to jersey
and i said
because you you're someone who doesn't
really make a decision
until you have to like you're not like
you don't you plan stuff but it's like
you're the only one who really knows the
plan sometimes
and i said it i must have said it to you
seven times i was like hey
i just want to make sure we're cool if
you had wanted to continue doing the
podcast i would have but now i've been
looking back at this year i don't think
there's even a question if if we made
the right choice
i miss you and hopefully i'll see you
soon in person
but it i i
going back to what i said last on monday
i don't think you could have written a
better
quote-unquote and and there was only
really an end to the podcast we're still
friends you still bust my balls three to
four days a week
you called me and asked me if i if i
called my ex and then
and if i if i licked an [__] yet and
uh
it it it was just a great guy we because
we were together for like nine cause we
did a lot of [__] before the podcast
even started
it uh and i wouldn't i wouldn't have
made it a year and a half in l.a if i
hadn't met you i would have been back in
boston anyways
so it was a a great experience
and i love you man it was great i love
you too i'm gonna smoke this for you
that's the devil oh [__] that's full
effect you know what i'm saying just so
i don't have anything [__] it you know
what i guess i do hold on
alonso bowden gave me this he gave it he
brought it to me from mexico
and he said he forgot to give it to me
the last time he was on so i said [__]
it
i got for old time's sake [__] i'm gonna
have to cancel a date tonight
these are true shout out to true leave
in florida they're 50 milligrams
[__] it might as well take one
for old times oh god they even smell
like weed what do you think they're
gonna smell like feet what the [__] is
wrong with you
they're capsules they're [__] little
red like this is the
devil oh yeah that's mixed with god
knows what
[__] the cat's from [__] korea
town oh
yeah oh yeah there's definitely cat
people if you're meowing tonight
no have you have you called milkshake
any of the girls to say hello
no the milkshake won't talk to me um the
girl in milwaukee
[__] her she broke your bed you
shouldn't talk to her that fat
[__] no we broke the bed that that
though
but i the girl on my walk i can't
believe i just took that it's [__]
one in the afternoon
but um the church is back [__]
that's right that was oh my god this is
fun i love you lisa i love you and i
want to give a quick shout out
to mike mike you're doing a great job
with this savage
doing great with everything mike did the
artwork for
uh what was i thinking and and uh
he's a great guy he has a great family
has always been a gentleman to me
and i'm so happy that that you guys have
each other and let me tell you something
the other day i told him i go mike
i'm trying to save you some [__]
energy time and heartache i don't want
you as a [__] co-host look what
happened to my last co-host
he went off the [__] defense all
right stop with the [__] co-host
sit there nice because i don't want two
co-hosts i already put one guy in to
[__] lulu land
smoking dope and you know he smokes dope
and he's all right
he could he could eat 200 milligrams but
he's skinny he's skinny mike if you ever
want to gain some weight i'll teach you
we're going to mcdonald's twice a day
and we're going to 7-eleven and getting
candy
[__] every day so you need to gain
some weight when you told me the story
about milwaukee that you fell asleep
with the [__] nutter butters
oh and the kids in the bed and the bad
the kid cats and you rolled up and you
had fudge in your eyes like a football
player you like gronkowski you had those
[__] things under your eyes
oh i was eating there were times i was
going to the fourth wall
just because i knew i could go to
7-eleven get candy or ice cream after
it was yeah that was like that was the
not good
times but now like i'm eating better
i'm gonna have to be [__] careful
tonight with that thing but uh
yeah we had it we had you know as as
much at
this podcast we talked about how some
some of the times weren't
the best for us when we were shooting
the podcast and
and and talking before and after and you
calling me at six in the morning for
three years straight
telling me to get up and like we we had
some
even even if i wasn't happy as a person
i still had some great times
i wouldn't trade it i i don't know i had
i had a life
and i think i might have even said this
on the last church
i'm a boring person man i i i
a millionth of what we did on the church
if if i hadn't
been on it and uh it's
it's just a great thing to uh to have
done
and and the fact that that i mean i get
to know you
and simone is one of my best friends
forever tripoli
it's one of the honestly one of the
coolest things about the pandemic has
seen
is seeing all the people who are taking
off and tripoli doing so well
is amazing uh tim dillon
blowing up is amazing it's great it's
just it's
it's cool to see like andrew schultz you
know what and i i said this on on
a podcast uh someone who i think
used to get a lot of [__] but i'm really
very motivated by is brendan schaub
the fact that all the work that he does
and theo too
but schab has so many things that he's
doing
he works so hard and
it's there's just so many comics get a
bad rap
for doing drugs and for being out
whatever
there's like look at ari do all the
stuff he's putting up
there's so many comics who as a
an entrepreneur or a content create
whatever you want to call it
that are just doing so much by
themselves and for themselves that it's
just like you had cassius morris on here
cassius morris is a young man now
we know him how long eight years nine
years and he
he's making his entire living from
podcasting
it's uh and then look seeing
you just said josh potter on he's
blowing up
it's um the thing that
that i learned so much from you is
that i was because i tried to start
podcast when i was with you
is consistency is really the most
important thing one of the things i love
doing is
looking i go on youtube and i go to like
a really popular youtuber but i go to
their first video
and they look like [__] the lighting's
terrible the sound's terrible
and but now they have a million
subscribers
and i one of the things that i always
struggled with was
i wanted things to be a certain way or
if i ran into an obstacle i would just
give up
and it's it's better
it's it's good to see that you know man
if you just try it it might change and
it might adapt
but if you just keep doing it good
things will happen
i feel the same [__] way guy this is
it
this is it twice a week you're nice
you do your thing i'm not here trying to
talk politics or trying to be a [__]
genius
i'm just trying to open up my heart to
people
so they don't do the same [__]
mistakes i did and at least if they do
them they know that
they could bounce back that's what this
whole movement for me has been about
right i love you little brother i love
you talk to you tonight
and uh yeah this was this whole week was
dedicated to church week
[__] i love the first week of july
and it's your birthday this month so
we'll give you a shout out thank you for
doing two episodes and
of course stay black we'll put them up
back to back [__] these [__]
that's right they got the church reunion
they wanted i love you buddy love you
too kick that meal mike
you kick that [__] meal mike give
that indian gin
love you lee love you too buddy love you
joe i don't think you can hear me
anymore but love you brother
okay i'll call you later all right buddy
thank you
what's happening you bad [__]
so
i'm happy see you guys wanted the church
reunion usually i tell you people go
[__] yourselves but after that
gentleman wrote that thing on twitter
saying how much we changed and how happy
he was and
hearing a couple people we finally got
a little respect for what we did and i'm
really happy for lee
that he's moved on i'm happy that i'm
getting to work with mike now
mike's a [__] sweetheart uh
somebody reached out to me that they
want to pitch the album to the week to a
television show because
it needs to be done and mike needs to be
the producer of it because
he does a great job but the thing about
a tv show with music
is you gotta get right from every
[__] i tried it already guys it's a
[__] nightmare
but anyway i don't want to take much
your time i know that was a long
interview that you wanted
and i try to keep the podcast up for an
hour i wanted to turn you guys on to
this too
today you guys saw we used at the end
this is gonna be the official pipe of
[__]
laughing gas reefer right here this is
tremendous
it's the devil himself look at this bad
[__]
that's an nft right there
that's laughing guys [__] and for you
[__] have a great week all
right
we're back in more ways than one
mentally physically spiritually
my dick is looking a little better hold
on fungi told report
fungi told report we're getting better
the [__] tea tree oil is working the
other day i buffed out my nails
i buffed out the skin around the nails i
killed all the fungus tremendous smoke
everywhere my wife came down she goes
it's dusty down here
i go that ain't dust [__] that's
[__] toe jam that's
that's all fungi toenail stuff i don't
call my wife a [__] you'll backhand me
but that's the way life is listen i love
you [__] with all my heart
if you're on patreon the nfts come out
today i think today yeah wednesday this
the seventh the nfts will be out and
that's it
and that's that guys it was a great
[__] week i hope you enjoyed lisa
you're like
jesus we didn't see lee for 10 months
then we got to see him two times in one
week yeah
that's how we do it here you know what
i'm saying always trying to strive to
bring you the best on a good podcast
guys i love you
with all my heart do not forget right
now do me a favor
go to at laughing gas with two g's at
the end
at laughing gas michael put a [__]
thing up here to say it
laughing gas on instagram to follow us
for sales where it's going to be located
specials
we're going to start with california
nevada i want you to know what stores
they're gonna be at
and uh that's all i wanted to say to you
guys it was a great week
i'm feeling better i'm happy you guys
are better
let's kick this [__] meal [__]
have a great weekend now for a word for
my [__] sponsor jack
all right i love you [__] thank
you very much
for watching uh it was great to see him
he's uh
a great guy but hey that's enough of
that now it's a word for our sponsors
the joint is brought to you
by manscape summer's here and you got to
be ready to show off your beach body
listen i went to the beach a couple
weeks ago i had to shave everything
my chest because i got white hairs i
shaved my [__] nut sack and it wasn't
even the beach it was the pool to be
honest with you
whether you're going to the beach the
pool whether you're going to be out in
public
you want to look good i even used
[__] my manscape to shave the afro on
my knee
it works on knees it works on balls and
it works on the area from around your
dick
listen what we're gonna do is this i'm
gonna come out with the fourth
generation or better yet
manskate's coming out with the fourth
generation performance package
first up they give you the new and
improved lawnmower
4.0 trimmer [__] tremendous if my
arms are long i'd show it to you
i'll give you a bunch of [__] mumbo
jumbo but listen it's
skin safe technology the bottom line is
it's designed to protect your privates
you're not going to cut your dick off
and throw it in the field and the cops
got to look for it even my long balls
don't get caught in these [__] things
and the blades are sharp enough
to cut through the white hairs like
butter you set the length of your trim
from one to four and if you're old
school you even make
the light brighter you had a travel lock
and they made it waterproof so you could
do it in the [__] shower
me i like to shave over the [__]
toilet you get deep in there
deep into the nut sack beep around the
dick pole
and you're ready to go throw this in
your weekend bag when you go away and
you're set for any situation
you pick some chick up or another guy
you can shave their [__] nuts or
their [__] [__] whatever the [__]
you're into
i mean it's uh gay pride month anyway
it's ending but it's gay pride every
[__] day in my world
and it don't stop at your nuts this
summer people going to be looking at you
from all angles
so you got to get the weed whack it
trims up your nose and your ear heads
with a 9 000 rpm motor this thing got
boogers out of my nose that have been in
there since the [__] 80s
and then you got my favorites the crop
preserver that's an anti-shaving ball
deodorant
i'll tell you what it works all [__]
days on your nut sack
but this is the product this is the
[__] creme de la creme creme creme
you ready for this the crop revival oh
my god
that's a ball toner tightens your nut
sack very nicely
and when you get the performance packet
they throw in a travel bag
and ready for this a nice pair of boxer
shorts what are you gonna get that
action at
for that price listen who's better than
you
better yet who's better than manscape
nobody
i'm gonna give you 20 off and free
worldwide shipping
by going to manscape.com joey again
that's 20
off and free worldwide shipping by going
to manscape.com
joey if you're stuck in the [__] uh
delta
variant and you're in england and
lockdown [__] it
at least you can see the ups guy when he
shows up with your manscape and you can
shave your nut sack your eyebrows
whatever the [__] you need
to be in shape when the lockdown is over
all right worldwide shipping
and 20 off at manscape.com
joey no more stinky hairs with manscape
go to manscape.com joey
i want to thank manscape but most
importantly i want to thank you guys for
having us back i want to thank lee cyan
for coming on and being honest and open
do not forget
nfts will be out today on patreon also
uh sign up at laughing gas
on instagram please immediately at
laughing gas at instagram
if you like smoking reefer that's the
[__] page
for laughing ass uncle joey's personal
[__] reefer
it's mixed up with ice cream shop that's
who's gonna be distributing it
out of studio city but if you register
if you sign up for at laughing gas
you'll know the other stores it's going
to be at
and they'll make your life and easier
and you can see where their specials are
i love you [__] thank you for
having the joint thank you for having
mine and mike's back
and we'll be back monday tip top magoo
on the [__] tent uh my mouth will be
hurting i'll be going to the dentist but
i'll still be here
i love you [__] stay black thank
[Music]
you
foreign
[Music]
you